-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
The White House is reportedly
planning to present
President Biden
with a birthday cake on Saturday
at his granddaughter's wedding.
And if you're wondering
how old he is,
he'll be at his
granddaughter's wedding.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
will celebrate
his 80th birthday on Sunday,
while Fox News will celebrate it
all year long, baby!
[ Laughter ]
In a speech today
from the House floor,
Speaker Nancy Pelosi announced
she will not seek another term
as Democratic leader,
but will remain in Congress
to finish her term.
Meanwhile, in the Senate,
his eternal curse
remains unbroken.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate yesterday
passed a bill
to expand medical-marijuana
research by unanimous consent.
They also decided,
by an 85-15 vote,
that unanimous is a funny word.
[ Laughter ]
Former White House
Chief of Staff
Mick Mulvaney
said in a new interview
that he thinks
former president Trump
is "the only Republican who
can lose in the 2024 election."
"Hold my beer,"
said Herschel Walker
to a mailbox.
[ Laughter ]
During a campaign stop
yesterday in Georgia,
Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
spent more than two minutes
trying to recount
plot details from
an untitled vampire movie.
Said Walker,
"Oh, it's not a movie."
[ Laughter ]
Tell 'em, mailbox.
At the same stop, Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker
talked about werewolves
and vampires and said,
"I don't want to be
a vampire anymore.
I want to be a werewolf."
Well, one thing's for certain,
he definitely doesn't
want to be a senator.
[ Laughter ]
Fans of the singer Morrissey
are upset
after he recently
ended his concert abruptly
after just 30 minutes
without any warning.
Fortunately, if there's
one thing Morrissey fans love,
it's when Morrissey
makes them upset.
[ Laughter ]
You know I'm zinging a couple
of old-high school girlfriends
with that one.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Japan had
to remove a 90-inch jump rope --
removed from his bladder
after he shoved the rope
into his penis.
On the bright side, he finally
got those kids off his lawn.
Do we have to show the X-ray?
A jump rope.
Microsoft yesterday added
a collection of classic games
to its Teams platform,
including solitaire.
Yeah, 'cause what says "teams"
more than solitaire?
The point is, you do it alone.
Did you also add "Cranking It"?
[ Laughter ]
We were doing the -- We're doing
that jump-rope-penis bit.
What's a good palate cleanser?
Let's use an early '90s slang
for masturbation.
That also reminds me of those
Morrissey fans.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida scientist recently
found an entire alligator
inside a Burmese python.
It's what -- It is -- Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
This is -- And I feel bad
because this is
maybe the tightest of
all the jokes.
This is maybe
the most tightly written,
and that's why I'm going to
take it back,
because, you know,
credit where credit's due.
Just try to think of anything
else to clear your mind.
Maybe the jump-rope penis.
A Florida scientist recently
found an entire alligator
inside a Burmese python.
It's what's called
a Florida turducken.
Pretty good joke.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We couldn't get the X-ray
of what that would look like?